wir fliegen zum mars das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex plant schon
für 2022 erste bemannte flüge zum roten
planeten und auch die nasa hat
angekündigt in den 30er jahren dieses
jahrhunderts menschen auf den mars zu
schicken
doch bis die technik wirklich so weit
ist muss noch einiges passieren
auf der internationalen raumstation
wurde deswegen vor kurzem einen langzeit
experiment durchgeführt durch welches
man herausfinden wollte wie sich das
dauerhafte leben im all auf den körper
auswirkt scott kelly ist ein
amerikanischer astronaut der sich 2015
fast ein ganzes jahr lang auf der iss
und somit in schwerelosigkeit befand
währenddessen gibt sein zwillingsbruder
mark kelly hier auf der erde zurück mit
hilfe von marc konnten die ärzte in der
nasa abschätzen wie sich scott körper
unter normalen bedingungen auf der erde
verhalten hätte und genauer betrachten
was mit unseren körpern in der
schwerelosigkeit passiert das ergebnis
erhöhte stress werte sauerstoffmangel im
blut verlust von knochenmasse und eine
veränderung des immunsystems die meisten
symptome verschwinden zwar nach einiger
zeit auf der erde
trotzdem können wir sagen dass ein
längerer weltraum aufenthalt unseren
körper langfristig verändert um die
folgen der schwerelosigkeit so gut es
geht zu kompensieren sind auf der iss
täglich mehrere stunden training
angesagt
gegen leberschäden die ausdehnung der
wirbelsäule und den verlust roter
blutkörperchen kann man allerdings
leider nichts unternehmen wenn wir
monate lange flüge zum mars und zurück
unternehmen wollen spätestens wenn wir
den rest unserer galaxie erkunden wollen
dann müssen wir herausfinden wie wir
gravitation im weltall erzeugen können
[Musik]
gravitation ist eine der grundlegenden
physikalischen kräfte es ist die
gegenseitige anziehung zweier massen
je größer die massen und je geringer die
entfernung zwischen ihnen desto größer
die anziehungskraft für uns auf der erde
ist sie die kraft die uns auf der
oberfläche hält und dafür sorgt dass wir
meistens wieder zum boden der tatsachen
zurückkehren wenn wir ihn verlassen
würden wir auf unserer raumstation eine
ähnliche anziehungskraft generieren
wollen dann müsste unsere raumstation
auch eine ähnliche masse wie unsere erde
besitzen das ist natürlich alles andere
als praktikabel
zum glück gibt es aber noch eine andere
kraft die uns erlaubt den effekt der
gravitation zu imitieren die
zentrifugalkraft
darf ich vorstellen die watson
enterprise gebaut von chris eade rom lag
dieses raumschiff kann sozusagen seine
eigene gravitation erzeugen und das nur
durch den einfachen trick der drehung
lassen wir die stationen rotieren dann
erfahren die insassen zwei kräfte von
außen betrachtet also stationär sieht es
so aus als würde unser bezugspunkt eine
radiale kraft in richtung zentrum
erfahren
zusammen mit der tangentiale
vorwärtsbewegung ergibt dies eine
kreisbewegung wenn wir uns das ganze
aber von innen anschauen unser
bezugspunkt also mit rotiert dann greift
die zentrifugalkraft oder auch
fliehkraft die euch das gefühl gibt an
die wand gedrückt zu werden
deswegen ist die wand der station auch
eigentlich der boden auf dem mann läuft
man steht also zumindest von außen
betrachtet an der wand dieses gefühl
kennt ihr vielleicht wenn ihr in einem
auto abbiegt und in die entgegengesetzte
richtung gedrückt werden es ist eine
folge der trägheit da sich unser körper
eigentlich noch geradeaus bewegen will
aber vom auto oder eben der raumstation
abgelenkt wird und auf der kreisbahn
gehalten wird bekommen wir das gefühl
nach außen gedrückt zu werden
die zentrifugalkraft wird deswegen auch
gerne als schein kraft bezeichnet wenn
wir uns also anschauen wie diese kräfte
zustande kommen erkennen wir dass
zentral oder eben zentrifugalkraft vom
radius und der drehgeschwindigkeit
abhängig sind beide kräfte sind gleich
groß und unterscheiden sich nur in ihrer
ausrichtung mit einer einfachen
berechnung lässt sich die stationen so
dimensionieren dass die fliehkraft
gleich der erdanziehungskraft ist
künstliche schwerkraft lässt sich also
durch eine einfache rotation erzeugen
mit dem einzigen unterschied dass der
boden jetzt nicht mehr unten sondern
außen ist quartiere oder lebensräume
befinden sich in der watson enterprise
deswegen ihrem äußeren teil wo die
rotation kräfte am größten sind
wenn wir uns die formel genauer
anschauen sehen wir dass zwei faktoren
die rotation kraft beeinflussen
wenn wir den radius der raumstation zu
klein wählen muss die
drehgeschwindigkeit erhöht werden um
dieselbe mutation kraft zu erhalten
wenn allerdings die drehgeschwindigkeit
niedriger sein soll dann müssen wir den
radius vergrößern
beide faktoren haben einen einfluss auf
unsere astronauten würde man aufrecht in
der watson enterprise stehen dann
erfahren kopf und füße unterschiedlich
starke kräfte da der abstand zum zentrum
also der radius variiert stark die
desorientierung und durchblutung
schwierigkeiten sind die folge hier auf
der erde gilt zwar dasselbe prinzip nur
sind die unterschiede aufgrund der
schieren größe unseres planeten so
gering dass wir es gar nicht merken
ein weiterer interessanter effekt
passiert wenn man sich auf der
raumstation bewegt wenn man nämlich mit
der drehbewegung der raumstation läuft
dreht man sich insgesamt schneller und
die anziehungskraft nimmt zu der körper
wird schwerer läuft man allerdings gegen
die drehbewegung dann nimmt die
anziehungskraft ab man würde also wenn
man schnell genug grant irgendwann
wieder anfangen zu schweben
die wahl der richtigen
rotationsgeschwindigkeit und größe der
raumstation sind essentiell
je größer der radius ist desto geringer
sind die unangenehmen nebenwirkungen auf
unsere astronauten wählen wir unseren
radius allerdings zu hoch müssen wir mit
ungeheuren materialkosten rechnen
außerdem würden die kräfte die auf die
station wirken irgendwann so groß werden
dass wir vermutlich eine neue methode
bräuchten um atome zu binden die kräfte
auf levins struktur aus ring world
während eine 6 milliarden mal so groß
wie die erdanziehungskraft das ist eine
eins mit 39 nullen bisher sind uns keine
materialien bekannt die dieser belastung
auch nur ansatzweise standhalten könnten
als fairen kompromiss haben wir bei der
watson enterprise deshalb 225 meter als
radios gewählt um ein g also die
erdbeschleunigung zu erreichen und die
gesundheit der astronauten nicht zu
gefährden musste sich ungefähr zwei mal
in der minute
um die eigene achse drehen zum vergleich
die iss besitzt eine spannweite von 73
metern bringt stolze 450 tonnen auf die
waage und hat geschätzte 150 milliarden
us dollar gekostet
unser schiff ist ungefähr sechsmal so
groß was würde also so eine raumstation
kosten
spacex aktuell der günstigste anbieter
in der raumfahrtindustrie berechnet
zurzeit zirka 5000 euro um ein kilogramm
gewicht in die umlaufbahn der erde zu
befördern und will diesen posten in
wenigen jahren auf knapp über 2.000 euro
senken
damit würden sich alleine die stadt
kosten für unsere station auf über sechs
milliarden euro belaufen
das ist viel aber gerade mal ein drittel
des jährlichen budgets der nasa und im
vergleich zu den raumstationen aus
science fiction ist das noch ein
schnäppchen
der standort tores ist ein konzept von
studenten aus dem jahr 1975 diese haben
eine station für 10.000 bewohner
entworfen die einen durchmesser von 18
kilometern besitzt und damit ganze zehn
millionen tonnen an material benötigt
allein die kosten um das material ins
weltall zu bringen während zirka 150
millionen euro wobei sich bei solchen
mengen lohnen würde material von
asteroiden zu farmen und die raumstation
im weltall herzustellen
die ring welt aus halo hat einen
durchmesser von sogar 30.000 kilometern
was das kosten würde kann man schon gar
nicht mehr vernünftig schätzen es wäre
ein projekt an dem die gesamte
menschheit jahrhunderte arbeiten würde
aber vielleicht muss es ja gar nicht so
teuer sein diese strukturen haben alle
eines gemeinsam sie besitzen alle eine
art ringen der um ein zentrum rotiert
doch es gibt auch andere konzepte die
die rotation kraft nutzen
so wurde es auch genügen eine kapsel
verbunden mit einem gegengewicht
rotieren zu lassen
die achse um die die konstruktion
rotiert befindet sich in der mitte der
verbindung da das sei dabei sehr stark
sein muss eignet sich das vielleicht
nicht für große stationen auf den
möglich menschen leben sollen sondern
eher für kleinere schiffe die für den
transport über große strecken gedacht
sind
wie ihr seht es ist durchaus möglich
künstliche gravitation zu erzeugen
das problem ist weder der bau noch die
physik dahinter sondern vielmehr wie man
das ganze gerät später ins weltall
bekommt bis wir das kostengünstig
hinbekommen wird die watson enterprise
wohl science fiction bleiben
so das war das erste video im neuen set
von doktor watson ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
ja ich bin inzwischen mit dem studium
durch und startet jetzt eine firma mit
zwei freunden und dazu gehört ein office
ein büro und eben auch dieses studio wo
wir ab jetzt die doktoren videos
streamen können ich das noch ein
bisschen da habe ich oben ganz
professionell sounds panels wir haben
eine eine die edelight die daran glauben
traversen an den decken hängen da hängt
das mikrofon ganz viele coole sachen und
ja ich freue mich einfach dass es jetzt
hier richtig losgeht quasi das ist
doktor watson nochmal professioneller
wird ich hoffe euch gefällt der neue
hintergrund so wir haben lange überlegt
wie wir den hintergrund den ich schon so
lange hatte bei doktor watson den ich
richtig geil fand eigentlich wie wir den
noch toppen können
ich bin echt ziemlich happy mit diesem
neuen design mit diesen etwas digitalen
design aber schreibt mir gerne meine
kommentare video das findet und
ansonsten hoffe ich dass es euch
gefallen hatte dass ihr jetzt bock habt
auf mehr doch trotzdem videos wie das
ganze hier behind the scenes aussieht
wie es aussieht könnt ihr euch gerne auf
ins programm angucken und vor allem auf
pagewizz und gerade jetzt zum start der
neuen firma freue ich mich natürlich
besonders über jeden einzelnen
unterstützer auf petri an alle links
unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bis zum nächsten mal
patrick
[Musik]